there was a great essay by Henry wise
Meyer called the death of aw in the Age
of Awesome one of the things that he was
saying is that our search for the
rhapsodic our search for that sense of
humbling in comprehension when we are
witnessing we are beholding something
that stretches our mental maps of the
possible that we are losing that in an
age in which the world seems to be
served for us packaged and sold as
mindless entertainment at any given time
that awesome places that become load
stars the Restless mind tells us you
know he talks about how reality is
coupled to perceptions the knobs and
levers of the perception that can be
tweaked by our pharmacological activity
our drug use our mediation the spaces
will dwell the places we go can induce
moment thing cause ontological shifts
moments that enlarge and radically
reconstruct our perspective right you
know Neil deGrasse Tyson talks about the
cosmic perspective Carl Sagan talk about
the pale blue dot that mote of dust
suspended in a sunbeam that is all we
have and all we are
these moments of humbling comprehension
right in which our body mind is
decommissioned from the trivial and
thrust into the numinous we become maybe
become something else something happens
we are transformed and you know what
happens empathy goes up compassion goes
up creativity goes up we realize right
as but the older used to say and I have
echoed we thought that we are the
captains of spaceship earth and so what
does that mean these our consciousness
is expanded right we sort of moved
forward in the sense of what we care
about we we start to realize that the
character and the care for the other is
to care for ourselves and to care for
ourselves is to care with each other and
if we can turn back those experiences
you'll be in a better place in terms of
the future of sort of entertainment and
mind expansion
you